I'm here. This is Diane Campione and I'm here at the G.C.C. interview for visible lives with
Amy Foxon.Hi Amy, Hi how are you? Who are you speaking about today?
We're speaking about my son Jason Foxman. He's four years old and was
diagnosed PDD-NOS at eighteen months-uh twenty one months I'm
sorry.  Can you tell me what made you suspect that he was different?
He- And at what age? -twenty one months. 'Bout nineteen-twenty months I started
he wasn't walking. Crawling was very difficult
difficult for him. He would just glide. On the furniture
No. Was not verbal no eye
contact. You could call his name a hundred times and it would be no
response. Um. He wasn't eating
the way he should be.
And I started to get worried and I got him a, I went for a, a hearing
test to make sure that it wasn't. That he wasn't deaf.
and they said his hearing was fine and that somebody recommended that we should be
Um, evaluated. So I took him to be
evaluated and they evaluated him as a PDD-NOS. And
we started home care for six months. And then
little by little I saw tiny changes but nothing substantial. And
then we enrolled him in Thursday's Child. And
a light bulb went off. And before you know it between
he would go to Thursday's Child in the morning and have home care 'til 6 o'clock at night. [door slam] 5 days a
week.
Between the two combined, what, there was a
huge, huge change. Huge change. He started to talk.
He finally said Mommy at 23, just around his
second birthday. He started to say mommy. But it would
come and go in phases.
There would be a phase where he would start to say little words...mommy and hi
bye, and no, and then it would stop.
And then nothing. And then it would start again. And he would
look at you, but you could see that he didn't know who you were.
And then the more, we went on and we went on and we went on
...
He just started to evolve.
And now, today, he's at 373 and 58, he's four
years old.
And I have a completely different child. Can you tell me
about the emotions? The day, your emotions, the day he was diagnosed?
...
I was distraught. One, because I didn't know. I didn't
know who he, what it was. And all I heard was autism.
Autism spectrum. Autism, autism. And I said
I, I said this can't be. This, this
This can't be. Autism doesn't run in my family and I don't know anybody who is autistic at that
time.
And. It was it was very overwhelming. But you can't
show it. I couldn't show it because I didn't want, if there were any signs my
son was picking up. Everything had to be happy and positive and.
I'd cry in the shower, I'd cry at
night when everybody was asleep or I would just sit and think and it
was a lot to take in because I didn't know anything at that time
...
What would you say the best word, or wh-, what word best describes
difficult stages of his disability?
The most difficult stages of his disability?
... uh,um.
It's rough. It's rough.
When we first started and he wasn't responding and he wasn't. It was all so
new to him. He didn't want any part of it. It was heartbreaking.
Because he couldn't communicate to anybody or tell us,
Tell us what he wanted.
And uh. He's my first child, he's my only child. And
. It was just, it was heartbreaking
. What would you say was the biggest obstacle you've had to overcome?
To hear that he's on the spectrum. For me.
. For me.
um. People who see him now would never
believe me when I tell them that he's on the spectrum. But
I don't want to make this sound
To..
To have that label. Be as honest as you like, if that's your feeling.  To be that, to have that
label. I don't know if it'll, if it'll be with him
. But the rest of his life because they had told me that, if he gets
transitioned into a regular kindergarten, all this will come off his record.
So I don't know but. I don't want him to feel different. I don't want him to feel
I want him to be a regular kid.  I want him to be a
regular kid. He still has his delays. He's still delayed in potty training. He doesn't
sleep in his own bed. He... always
thinks. He thinks too much. He'll speak and then he thinks,
he thinks too much. And you can see the wheels turning
and he doesn't know how to express what he wants. Sometimes.
And he throws tantrums. I don't know which of it is typical four year old
and which is part of his disability. But just to know
that he has. Or. That I'm talking about my son with a
disability. Yes, say it. It, it irks me.
Do you ever feel you gave up your life to give him a life? No. Well,
Well. There are a lot of things I don't do anymore.
. Yeah, I don't see a lot of friends anymore. I don't.
My husband I don't have a lot of, quiet time together
or date night or, or anything like that. Everything is, we're
all about, Jason. Twenty four - seven. It's Jason.
. Do you ever ask why? I did.
...And
In the beginning. I did.  But there was no answer why.
It is what it is. Is there something you would like the public to know about
individuals such as yourself that have a child
Within the spectrum?  Hang in there. Hang in there and be strong.
If you need to cry, the shower is the best place to do it.
But, you will, there is a light at the end of the tunnel
there. Even if it's the most minute thing,
it's a huge milestone for, for them and to see a smile on their face
Or especially my son's face, makes everything worthwhile.
When he said "Mommy I love you. Thank you for doing this for me"
That. That's all I need. Finish this
sentence for me. I draw my strength from... My son.
My son is the reason I wake up in the morning. He's the reason. My son and
my husband. My husband's very strong. My husband,
we've been through a lot. Prior to Jason. During Jason
...But,
Without the two of them,
Life doesn't matter. Thank you so much for sharing his story.
Amazing lady. Thank you. I am so happy that other people will learn from your
experiences. And I just want to say thank you. Thank you.